will boardman asks how have you overcome
dyslexia throughout your life dyslexia
uh it's a good question i didn't know i
had it my mom told me that i took an
experimental she had allowed us to do an
experimental
way of learning how to read in the 70s
when i learned how to read i don't know
the name of it and she thinks that might
have
made it worse for me
but i didn't realize it until you know i
was in my 30s and i just had somebody
had to explain to me
uh there there and there again or two
two and two again and the way i was able
to fix this was i
asked people around me to tell me when i
mispronounced something and to tell me
when i misspelled something and then i
would take the time to write down in a
book
there t h e i r t h e y approximate r e
t h e r e and i would just write it i
would write it and see it and say it out
loud
and when i would write it and say it out
loud it would click for me and now
my actual grammar and vocabulary
have all skyrocketed since i just
started writing and saying things out
loud so for some reason for me when i
speak something and i type it and i see
it
so i'm having all modalities at once
it kind of gets me through it so that
it's as simple as that and then i'm not
embarrassed about the fact that i
mispronounce names because sometimes
when i get it right
i can say poly hoppity over and over
again
you know and it just clicks for me just
it just takes a little more time and
thoughtfulness and there's also a piece
of software called hemingway app and
another one called grammarly
and they were unlocked for me because
when i started running things through
grammar or text to speech
this was actually a key for me i started
using text-to-speech like decades ago
and i would pay for like dragon software
when it was really expensive it was like
desktop software now it's built into
you know every operating system because
of
accessibility and you turn if you turn
on accessibility on your phone you can
get a little um
uh overlay that will let you highlight
any text and turn it into
speech when you hear something as a
dyslexic person that you misspelled it's
clear as day i don't know if every
dyslexic person is like that but i know
i am
when i read it
it makes sense to me but then i hear it
i'm like oh that's wrong and so then i
was like okay so from now on when i
wrote the book
i would literally take out a microphone
and i would speak the chapter and then i
would go for a walk and i would listen
to it and if it didn't sound right to me
i would think about another way to say
it
and that was a way for me to workshop to
be a more compelling writer but it was
also a way for me to get through the
dyslexia stuff so i you know i never
went to any kind of dyslexia training or
anything but i think you can make up for
it with other aspects which is if you're
a good writer
if you have a great vocabulary if you're
knowledgeable if you're well spoken if
you don't um and ah
you know everybody's got their
particular
i don't know challenges and so some
people say you know you know you know
or they were they um and ah i don't do
that anymore
so uh and my vocabulary has gotten
better and better and i'm funny i can
make a quick joke like a thing on the
fly so you can make up for whatever your
weaknesses i think you just work on the
other things right so like if you're
just not good
at
you know i don't know if you know if
you're dennis rodman and you're just not
a good shooter like become the world's
greatest rebounder and
be the guy who frustrates the other
team's best offensive player right you
can
draymond green ever you know and i'm
friendly with draymond and like
you know i've talked about this very
issue with him every summer he like gets
better at something i don't know if you
saw last year the number of assists he
was putting up but he was like had games
with double digit assists all the time
what was what was draymond's assists
last year or the year before i mean
he's got to have five six seven assists
a game i think
you know and for his position i think it
would normally be two or three right so
i was very impressed with his ability to
add something new to his game